Michael welcome to America fest I know
you're on the road and I really
appreciate you squeezing us in but I'm
gonna I'm gonna open my kimono a little
bit here okay become everybody when I
heard people tell me that certain human
beings in our country are saying that
words equal violence even I who've been
through the wringer in the White House
called all kinds of names had my family
attacked I said no that's just stupid
nobody's that asinine but we have the
audio Michael how bad is it
it's unbelievable I know I mean you've
been in it as much as anybody and yet it
appalls even me even you because what
the left is doing now is so cynical it's
so transparent
they cannot defeat conservatives in
debate they cannot defeat conservatives
in discourse or argument so what they
have to do is they have to try to get
the Conservatives censured for campus or
kicked off campus when that doesn't work
the only way that they can shut them
down is by equating words with violence
because if words are violent then it
justifies their violence against
conservatives and I got to tell you I
know I'm from New York I live in Long
Island California so I I'm used to crazy
leftist but I figured in Georgia in
parts of America that are not totally
destroyed like the Northeast and
Southern California
I figured things weren't that bad and I
was wrong there was actually a professor
at the Kennesaw State University last
night she teaches a course called sex
and love which frankly are two of my
favorite subjects hang on don't forget
cigars sex lines of Gaza third that's
the trifecta
but this professor was so offended that
I had been invited to campus that she
actually demanded that her students
instead of going to class in her
classroom at Hearst to attend a rally to
protest my speaking that is how
outrageous the colleges have gotten now
what were they protesting what did I
said that it irritated them
they think that you weren't did they
think that you weren't in favor of sex
and love Michael Nolt I know they've
never listened to a word that I said
I have been a longtime proponent of both
of those things you know what this does
seem to me is that these kids are really
really angry about something and I
actually think their anger is is
somewhat justified they've been
completely failed by the educational
system they're going to college going
$200,000 in debt and learning virtually
nothing they know nothing about their
own civilization they have been failed
by their parents they've raised without
a culture they've been raised without a
privilege they've been raised to believe
half their country is deplorable an
irredeemable and so they're extremely
angry obviously they're not angry at
anything I'm saying I mean the most
controversial thing I said up towards
the end are not women what the men are
not women I know I know you hate
analyzing you too but listen this is the
question I have to ask that that girl
will save that order that will go into
the evergreens of the ROI please if she
says a myriad or whatever of of women of
color are dying because of the
intersectionality of pot noodle and
chicken casserole I mean I couldn't
quite follow it but she actually
believes this stuff doesn't she yes I
mean that's the scary thing they believe
it the trouble is if it were just
students saying stupid things that's
sort of the definition of a student
students are ignorant that's why they're
going to college right trouble is they
didn't hear this in their own
imagination I didn't this is the kind of
concept the idea that speech is violence
the idea that if a conservative comes up
in the speech that he's actually
uttering people this is what they've
been fed by their teachers and by their
professors and by their parents and by
the popular culture and so they really
do believe it they really are is
hysterical as they sound on that video
and the trouble is with what the
professor's do is they say hey don't you
dare go listen to that conservative
speaker actually give this lecture
you've just got to come here so that we
can rile you up and scare you even more
and and basically exploit
to advance our political agenda yeah
do you think there's a tipping point
Michael Knowles do you think that the
the insanity gets so Loutre so
over-the-top
that America is just gonna say oh please
shut up yes we're at the tipping point
we are living it right now this is
actually why I've called my speaking
tour men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths we're going to go
you know when we were at tennis oh we
the speech was actually on the
mainstream media why that's fake news
we're gonna give a speech tomorrow at
the University of Florida in Gainesville
about how leftism is not compassionate
it's all these obviously true things
that are being buried but it's that
central one and are not women that is
the truth that I think the vast vast
majority of people are finally opening
their eyes and saying you know if the
left in America is actually trying to
convince us that men or women and women
are men they're trying to convince us
not to believe our lying eyes they've
gone too far maybe they're telling us
some other lives - where can people find
out more are you doing this under the
aegis of yes yes this is all on ya a
young America's Foundation so you can
watch it if you're not able to get the
games really yes YouTube channel I'm
also going to be a politican in
Nashville on Sunday I'm going to be
debating the Democrat Chris Hahn that
should be alright if you are if you are
another hater like Michael Knowles who
thinks men are not women then follow him
yeah there's an amazing job on YouTube
and giving us the best clips of his
speeches god bless you Michael follow
this man Michael J knows be safe out
there my friend